hello everyone and welcome to the final
game we'll be showing from the
penultimate round of the 2021 norway
chess it's ariantari vs alireza firuja
and again it's quite uh quite an
incredible game now also from the
classical time format uh let's check it
out as there's uh quite a lot to cover
so tari with the white pieces opens with
e4 and you know what that means if first
is playing black he of course goes for
the sicilian defense we have c5 uh
knight to f3 d6 and now d4 we have
captures captures knight to f6 knight to
c3 and now again ferruccio goes for his
uh neither variation and often we
mention add that you can go for quite a
lot of moves here like bishop e3 bishop
g5 bishop e2 bishop c for moves like um
h3 are possible we've covered quite a
few games recently with the atoms attack
so basically any move here is a fine
move but here we have a4 by tari
and now what do you play here well uh
you will not have the usual b5 as now we
have that covered and now white would
even be interested in maybe playing a
move like f4 at some point
so of course black will prevent this by
playing e5 and this also chases away the
knight from such a very nice active
square so knight back to f3 and now uh
the usual moves here are bishop to e7
preparing for castling queen to c7 also
just a nice developing move from the
queen
blocking bishop to c4 uh but here we
have h6 by ferugia and now if this was
played in uh for example in morphy's
time or even in bobby fischer's time if
you know someone was commentating on the
game and they saw a6 h6 they'd be like
what is is black a child but nowadays
with the help of extremely powerful
engines we know that these moves
definitely make sense and they're not a
waste of time so here knight to d2 again
you could continue with some like bishop
to c for his perfectly normal developing
move but now comes knights to d2 by tari
sort of breaking chess principles a
little bit as you've already played with
that piece this knight is coming now to
c4 and he wants to bring this knight to
d5 so bishop to e6 by ferugia getting
some control of the d5 square knight to
c4 and now you might have some ideas of
bishop to e3 going for that b6 uh square
also a5 is coming so that's what white
is doing here uh and now again queen to
c7 unknown move here but now we have
bishop to e7 by firuja and it is now
already as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game and now tari uh
again does not continue development he
just plays knights to d5 and these
knights are breaking basically every
principle known to man every chess
principle uh saying that uh all right my
knights are very nicely placed and i
have my eyes uh a sight set for for that
b6 square uh and the question is can you
capture an e4 there are quite a few
lines in the sicilian where this e4 pawn
can be offered and if black captures
then you go bishop to e3 and now you
really have a lot of pressure here the
threat of course is now
just bishop to b6 attacks the queen and
after you move the queen knight c7 check
and white wins the game but here we
would see castles and then we would see
something like knight c the b6 attacking
the rook here and after rook to a7 now
we can pick up this bishop with check
queen captures and knight back to d5
opening up a discovery to the rook and
attacking the queen and after bishop
captures we would play bishop captures
on a7 and now knight back to f6 so this
was kind of tarry's idea uh not thinking
that alireza would go for this but this
is what happens if black goes for that
pawn so black is up upon but he's down
the exchange and white has the bishop
pair so white is white is definitely
better here so alireza says i will not
have any of that i'm just gonna remove
that knight from d5 you spent a lot of
moves getting it there so let's just
eliminate it and now you've just spent a
lot of moves and you don't have the
knight so e captures on d5 now we have
the ship to f5 and now a5 so white has
compensation for wasting all of these
tempe
you can see that the pawn here really
does a nice job of controlling a lot of
squares the a5 pawn controls b6 the
knight can come to b6 it will so uh
quite a lot for for black to worry about
actually we have knights to d7 gaining
more control of the b6 square and now
the ship to e2 both players are now
ready to castle and they do so castles
castles uh and now queen to c7
developing the queen preparing to bring
the rook uh
the c8 and you will constantly have this
pressure uh on the
on the c2 pawn so here firuja brings the
bishop to e sorry atari brings the
bishop to e3 now you gain more control
of the b6 square and now bishop back to
h7 clearing a space for f5 to be played
if you can get f5 f4 in you will be very
happy so here furuga says all right i
don't really enjoy this here and i'm not
in the mood uh you know for a move like
c3 i'm just gonna play rook to a3 this
not only allows me to move like rook to
c3 if needed uh the queen is on c7 but
also if my dark square bishop moves
anywhere then i will have access to the
entire third rank maybe i can easily
shift this uh
rook into the attack so rook a2c8 by
feruja and now king to h1 this is always
a question whether or not you should
play king to h1 it's always a nice
prophylactic move sometimes it's useful
sometimes it's not but if you've ever
tried playing a serious
game against a strong opponent for
example you play e4 he plays the
sicilian and you don't play king to h1
chances are you will run into trouble so
here king to h1 always a nice
prophylactic move and now f5 by ferruja
grabbing more space here so tari doesn't
want to allow f4 he pushes f4 himself
and now puts pressure on the e5 square
and now uh grabbing more space with e4
kind of looks nice but it basically uh
traps your bishop on h7 that bishop will
not see the light of day for for a very
long time and we can even go for
something like bishop d4 now white's the
bishop is great and if you counter the
bishop here we can simply capture it for
example captures captures play b4 and we
are very happy here black's bishop is
non-existent we have absolute control of
everything that's happening on the queen
side this knight is not moving from here
so the queen and rook are useless on
this uh that on this file and the rook
can easily be shifted anywhere uh along
the third rank so white is definitely
enjoying this so e4 would be a
positional mistake so bishop to f6 by
ferruja now comes b4 by tari
uh definitely makes sense strengthens
his position and now at some point if
this knight could move and you execute
c4 then you will be very very happy at
least on the queen side so rook the e8
ferrous agrees there's really no point
in remaining on the c file and now he
wants to double up his rooks here and
then maybe only then capture and do try
and do some damage along the e file so
queen to d2 and now rook to e7 and now
they're not waiting for for any doubling
of the rooks to occur we have f captures
on e5 uh and now uh because the rook is
on e7 you do not have the option of
capturing with the pawn because now d6
wins the game for tari as
you're going to lose a lot of material
here so instead you have to capture
either with the bishop or the knight the
furuja decides to capture with the
knight and now knight to b6 uh finally
the knight comes to b6 and it's always a
great square for the knight but here in
this particular position it doesn't
appear like there's all that much for
this knight to be doing here because
there's really no pieces on the queen
side you're not coming to d5 you're not
coming to d7 so this night although you
know visually
placed very nicely maybe you know
that's all that that it's doing uh and
here ferocious has to decide whether he
wants to double up on the e file now or
keep this rook on the f file and maybe
use it for some f4 f3 action in the
future all depends so he decides to go
for knight to g4 puts pressure on the
bishop here and now bishop to f4 just
getting it out of the way and now the
real question for firuja is do we
continue in
a great style with the g5 or do we
prepare it with rook f2e8 g5 right away
uh is very very interesting as uh if for
example bishop back to e3 then we have
this very annoying bishop to beat you
move attacking the rook and after the
rook moves attacks the bishop now we
capture on e3 and then after rook
captures we're gonna play knight
characters on e3 queen captures now f4
and now look at this we have this
beautiful pawn expansion here our bishop
pair is well fully operational this is
just a monstrosity of a bishop pair uh
and we we don't really have a worry in
the world so this would be possible uh
but ferocious prepares the first rook
after e8 that he says there's no
point in rushing this g5 is coming so
here the bishop is under fire you have
to move it bishop to f3 and only now g5
uh but now okay now we're gonna capture
on g4 so bishop captures on g4 and now
how do you reply if if you go for uh
capturing of this bishop then the
problem is this bishop can move with
tempo the rook is attacked and then it's
hard to say what is happening here this
is a complete mess of a position you
could go rook to e3 go after the a3
rogue but still your rook here is
attacked and for example if we capture
this black will capture this we're going
to capture on f4 and who's to say what's
happening here completely crazy position
so instead after bishop to g4 we don't
have g captures on f4 we have f captures
on g4 now the dark the dark square
bishop has to move uh bishop to e3 and
now
uh firuja finds this uh incredible uh
dead silent but the deadly rook to f7
and he's uh setting a very very deadly
trap and you have to be very very
careful uh here toddy played c4 and uh
it makes sense uh the c2 pawn is
attacked by the queen by the bishop so
you kind of don't want to lose this one
and we already discussed if this pawn
ever reaches c4 then this is just a
beautiful position for white here on the
queen side uh everything is nicely
placed and he doesn't have a worry in
the world aside from the fact that this
move loses atari the game so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
uh
well incredible move that furuja
prepared on the previous move while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the rook on f1 is undefended but that
your rook is not on f8 so the white will
not be able to capture it with check and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show of course it's uh bishop the b2
that's the good stuff uh and now what do
you play here uh well
uh the bishop can be captured the bishop
can be captured by the queen but what
does this do if bishop if queen captures
bishop then we simply play rook captures
on f1 bishop back to g1 and now rook
comes to e1 and it's game over there's
no defense against this um
it's completely winning there's
absolutely nothing you can do here you
can't even try and give up the queen for
two rooks because we can just capture
the queen here and of course the bishop
cannot capture so there's that so of
course the queen captures on b2 cannot
be played here uh of course we're gonna
move this rook first so rook captures on
f7 but now queen captures on f7 again uh
the bishop hangs as the queen is
threatening queen to f1 but there is
nothing better uh there there's no way
to stop this you're either losing the
rook or you're going to move the rook
somewhere and still suffer this queen to
f1 fate for example if rook to a2 we
just deliver queen to f1 check
bishop to g1 only move
and now i know what you guys are
thinking you want to play rook to e1 but
that would be a big problem for us so
rook to e2 that's what you have to play
and now there is no defense against the
queen captures on g2 checkmate white
just has to give up the queen so the
bishop obviously has to be captured but
it doesn't help tari all that much he
captures the bishop but now firuja goes
queen to f1 check bishop to g1 and now
again not rook to e1 rook to e2 now
checkmate is unstoppable and to prevent
this thought he has to give up the queen
so queen captures an e2 was played queen
captures and now rook to e3 he still has
this beautiful pawn formation here he
still has uh uh
uh a knight and a rook for a queen so of
course he will still continue playing
this uh we have queen to c2 now a very
annoying move as the knight now can't
move because the c4 pawn uh will fall
you don't really have any good moves
with the bishop the rook uh also really
not any active moves but the real threat
is bishop to e4 just going for checkmate
which will force the white rook to go
into a more uh even more passive
position so here c5 was played trying to
go for d captures and then d6 creating a
pass pawn but now the ship to e4 of
course we're going for checkmate rook to
g3 defending and now d captures on c5 we
have d6 preparing d7 and d8 but furuja
says this is not a problem c captures on
b4 we have d7 and now just queen to d2
stopping this past pawn uh we have rook
captures on g4 by tari going after the
bishop here bishop to c6 and now even
bishop to d for cutting off the queen's
uh reach to the to the d8 square now
we're threatening the promotion
but it is much too late for such things
so bishop captures on d7
knight captures and now yes you have a
bishop a knight and a rook for a queen
but there is b3 and you could also go
queen d1 check bishop to g1 and pick up
the knight here it's possible but then
you lose the b for pawn so uh you're
you're playing against the rook and
bishop which can be quite annoying so if
you instead plays b3 of course white
will have to give up the piece for the
pawn uh we have h3 creating some
breeding room for the king b2 now and
now you have to capture it bishop
captures on b2 queen captures now it's a
knight and the rook against the queen
but the the place on both sides of the
board so maybe playing against the
knight is a little bit easier as the
bishop can cover a lot more distance so
king to h2 uh queen to c3 now going
after the a5 pawn and what you play here
we have rook to g3 not just queen
captures on a5 we have knight to f6
check of course uh toddy will still try
our rook and the knight are our great
team uh we have king to f7 now comes
knight to g4 we have king to g7 now
comes rook to d3 trying to do some
damage uh but the queen c7 check king to
h1 and now a5 now if yoruji was just
start pushing his past pawn and he knows
that uh nothing can really be you know
done here so knight the e3
getting the knight in range of uh some
checks maybe if black blunders the queen
maybe you know he can still do something
but just a4 we have knight to f5 cher
king to g6 now comes g4 again maybe rook
to d6 and some good things might happen
but here just queen the c1 checked by
ferruja and he was in this position on
mu 51 that arientari resigned the game
and what an amazing victory for for
ferugia
who uh is now well we're going to
discuss the standings but who is doing
very very well in this tournament now so
here you resign because you have to move
the king and once the queen king moves
doesn't really matter anywhere on the
second rank everything is bad just queen
c2 check picks up the rook and that's it
of course there's no point in continuing
this
so let's check out the standings before
we forget these are the standings after
nine rounds of amazing classical chess
and armageddon so carlson leading with
18 points followed by uh richard rapport
uh sorry rihard rapport and alireza
ferrugia 16 and a half 15 points uh
yanni pomishi in fourth place with 11
within and half sergey karyakin and
aryanthari in sixth place with six
points so what does this mean for the
final round who can win the tournament
well if magnus magnus is playing against
nepo in the final round so that's really
really nicely nicely done uh and if
magnus wins the classical against nepo
today it's all over then magnus wins the
tournament however if if he doesn't
rapport is playing ferugia in the final
round so anything can happen if magnus
loses against nepo he stays on 18 points
okay maybe he wins uh no if it's a draw
okay he can still grab half a point in
the armageddon but let's say he loses
the classical uh and rapper to wins the
classical against ferruja then rapper
wins the tournament if furuja wins the
classical against rapport and magnus
loses the classical then it will be 18
points ferruja 18 points magnus and then
we're going to have a blitz tie break
between magnus and ferugia and if both
of those games of blitz end in a draw
we're going to have the final armageddon
between first and magnus so anything can
still happen uh it could be a short day
but could be a very very long day we'll
see but uh you know we are uh
in for
we are definitely in for a treat uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish happy
birthday to matthew tabute and i would
like to thank uh saisondrala yeah
philippe
giorgio dimitri samsonov and john
dukedale for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the final
round of this amazing tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and sorry about a bit of a
longer video but i hope it was justified
see you soon